I want to know are you bullish or
bearish about Humanity's prospects and
on a scale of one to ten ten being
certain near-term human extinction one
being Topia sunshine and rainbows where
do you think we fall right now as a
father and as a scientist as a man of
science I'm caught in this ambiguity of
not knowing where the future will take
us but wanting to be prepared and the
hardest thing in life is to be in the
middle and that doesn't mean to think of
you know everything sunshine and Roses
half the time and then everything's Doom
and Gloom half the time it's knowing
what to pay attention to and what to
ignore there have been a hundred billion
people that have lived in the span of
homo sapiens on this Little Rock of a
planet if you ask them would you like to
live now or when you live the
preponderance of people would say right
now you know plus or minus a few years I
I think it's a golden age it's the best
of times it's the worst of times it has
the potential for this very annoying
aspect for the human mind which is
ambiguity
[Music]